empeora el estado de salud del rey del
fútbol de 82 años el último boletín
médico habla de una progresión de la
enfermedad oncológica y cita
disfunciones renales y cardíacas que
requieren más cuidados de momento está
en un cuarto común no está recibiendo
cuidados intensivos pero recordamos que
está hospitalizado en San Pablo desde el
29 de noviembre para tratar un cáncer de
colon y una infección respiratoria el
último boletín médico era del 12 de
diciembre hablaba de una mejora de su
estado de salud especialmente de la
infección respiratoria sin embargo hoy
sus hijas han acudido a las redes
sociales para decir que no van a poder
celebrar la Navidad que van a tener que
pasarla en el hospital y han agradecido
el apoyo de los fans porque Pelé es
considerado realmente el rey del fútbol
en ese país y hay una auténtica
veneración por el exjugador recordamos
también que pelea ha estado muy activo
desde su cuarto de hospital durante
todos los mundiales el sábado pasado
publicó una carta abierta de sus redes
sociales en la que hablaba de sueños de
amor y lamentaba la exclusión de la
canariña de la selección de fútbol de
Brasil de los mundiales